we're going to catch it we're going to
have somebody that we trust that could
be your husband that could be your
girlfriend of yours that could be a
counselor whatever but all we're going
to do is when we feel our body when one
kid's running around and you say stop
running and they just keep running and
instantly that's it right there your
body dumps into your own kid won't even
listen to you
yeah wait a way to be nice mom
and then you yell or snap and then
you're like ah and you're a terrible mom
too
we're just gonna stop right there and
we're literally gonna put our hand on
our chest and we're gonna feel our
bodies
and we're going to Exhale really deep
and say
that's not true I'm not a terrible mom